this week on
brian ross investigates it's supposed to
be president trump's triumphant week
even with a virtual convention but the
manhattan district attorney sy vance
is close to getting the trump tax
returns in an investigation officials
say
involves tax insurance and bank fraud
win or lose this november donald trump
and his trump organization
could face criminal charges we'll talk
with john moscow a former top prosecutor
in the district attorney's office
and david k johnston a pulitzer
prize-winning journalist who has tracked
donald trump's every move
delay delay delay is the name of the
game for trump
plus dramatic new evidence revealed in
the case against a man known as the
apostle
the leader of a church that claims 5
million members
in court he was depicted by california
prosecutors
as anything but holy he is a sexual
deviant
predator state agents describing how he
uses the power of his religious
authority
to terrify the young girls they say have
become his sex servants
when she was taught within the church if
god is mad at you you could be
quote unquote struck down by lightning
cut in half
and we'll hear from one of the young
women who has paid the price
for coming forward and challenging the
apostle
you can't tell him to stop
you can't tell him no plus this week's
winners and losers in the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of meteorite
you do lead the coronavirus task force
as of this morning 174
000 americans have lost their lives to
this pandemic
from the law and crime trial network
this is brian ross investigates
and good evening thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live and youtube live
i'm brian ross joined tonight by my
colleague at the law and crime network
rhonda schwartz and rhonda we begin with
shocking new allegations against a man
called
the apostle he's the leader of a
worldwide church that claims to have
5 million members in the united states
mexico
and 50 other countries around the world
rhonda
he was arrested last june brian a year
ago june and he faces
36 felony counts human trafficking
in children for lewd sex acts production
of child pornography
and forcible race rape of a minor
and a warning to our viewers what you're
about to see while it took place in
court
includes language that is both graphic
and disturbing
the church says it has more than 5
million members in 53 countries around
the world
and to them mason joaquin garcia is
known
as the apostle as jesus christ on earth
but over the last two weeks in a los
angeles courtroom garcia has been
depicted by state investigators
as anything but holy this man
is a predator he has been under arrest
for rape
child pornography and sex trafficking
for more than a year now
the hearings were determined if there
was enough evidence to go to trial
and whether he should be able to post
bond
parishioners adult women
turn up lined up because he's the
apostle
everything he does and anything you do
to him even though it seems wrong
is going to be forgiven because he
is basically god on earth
that's what they preach the charges
against garcia by the california
attorney general
involved allegations from six people
identified as jane does one through five
and a john doe agent troy holmes was
questioned by prosecutor
amanda plessner did jane deford tell you
whether she wanted to have sex
with defender garcia the first time that
she did objection
she did what did she tell you said she
did not want to have sex with him
she discussed um
feeling like she couldn't couldn't say
no because
um being scared of him in the sense of
not wanting to make him mad
did you before telling you why she cared
about her defending garcia
yeah she said they'd do with her
spirituality and um what she was taught
spirituality and what she was taught
within the church
she discussed um if she
felt like if she made him mad that would
make god mad
and she was taught within the church if
god is mad at you you could be
quote unquote struck down by lightning
cut in half
um put in a wheelchair that sort of
thing so she
it was like a physical harm she was
taught if god was mad at her
and she was taught that by or did jacob
tell you about his teachings of the lulu
church yes also charged with garcia are
two women senior church members alondra
ocampo
and susannah osaka accused of recruiting
and grooming the young girls
for garcia's sexual acts campo told the
group that she was going to tell them
something special she told them about
god and about bible bible verses
ocampo told the group about that
about god allowing a king to take a
woman
to please him and
serve him and that uh
anything an apostle of god did was in
favor of god
and if they went against any of his
desires or wishes they were going
against
gods she told them it would be
she said it would be an abomination to
desire to deny his desires
in any way and agents testified that
garcia was able to use his power as the
leader of the worldwide church
to choose girls of the right age and
background
the defendant would want to know the age
the names and often the family or
church connection to the girls because
he would direct their grooming based off
how close the member the family was
to the church because he wanted
everything to stay very much close knit
and didn't like outsiders
agents testified that when garcia was
arrested as he stepped off a private
plane
at los angeles international last year
they were able to seize his phone and
other electronic devices
that contain hundreds if not thousands
of graphic
photos and sex tapes the series of
videos
is multiple girls
engaged in their
naked or nude um engaged in oral sex
uh vaginal penetration what i would
describe as an
orgy on a bed
how many about approximately how many
girls approximately six
and you said they're nude yes the
apostle
wearing a mask with his handcuffs
attached to a waist chain
looked on showing little reaction as
other videos were described
there were those four girls and there
was a combo
ocampo according to jane doe number one
ocampo took videos and photographs of
this incident
complimented seemed like a playful
event with whipped cream and what
jane doe number one described as weird
stuff
uh the girls were naked and acombo told
them to put whipped cream on each other
and to kiss each other and made them
touch each other
on their breasts and vaginal areas and
then a description of a video with
garcia and a young
boy in a mask and an older woman
you could see the confidential
male victim laying on the bed
still wearing the mask unclothed
you can see azalea ringel oral
copulating the boy
also having sexually you know having
sexual intercourse with him
around the five minute mark in that
video defending garcia
comes into view of that video and he is
recording
a different angle of the sexual acts
that are occurring with his iphone
were you able to do speculation
foundation were you able to see
mr defender garcia's face
in the video sufficient to identify him
absolutely
agents testified that garcia's position
as the apostle
as the leader of the light of the world
church made him
uniquely dangerous a contention that was
challenged by garcia's lawyer
and you believe you told judge hunter
and you're testifying now that that
particular religious doctrine
is one of the things that makes mr
garcia so dangerous if released correct
yes i think it's a it's a piece of the
puzzle
of of why he he could be so dangerous is
because of the belief of the church
and and the followers and it's just one
piece of the puzzle
you said is that if released
as the authoritarian leader of a church
whose millions of members regard him as
something of a demigod
upon his release he would immediately
return to a position of
omnipotent power within lldm
what's your basis for that assertion
victim and witness testimony
mr holmes you wrote that if released and
i'm just continuing on the next sentence
he would have unfettered access to
countless potential victims
who would feel religiously obligated or
otherwise coerced
into complying with his relentless
sexual demands
counsel you don't receive the calls i
received these these victims only these
victims
but these people in general have spoken
out of the church are terrified
there's online threats every day against
these people they're terrified they're
scared to death that this guy this
gentleman over here is going to get out
of jail
garcia's lawyers also challenged why
each of the alleged victims who
claim they were raped or abused by
garcia never said no
or sought outside help so as we sit here
today there's no evidence
of any objection being covered by her
i mean vocalized correct correct at the
time
okay um
she didn't call the police correct
correct you indicated that
um daniel 5 told you that he
that he my client quote grabbed her
and rolled her onto the back correct
yeah grabbed her by her waist and pulled
her towards him
and rolled her rolled her over and then
he was on top of her before he ever
touched her
she was touching him first right
i believe she was giving a foot massage
or some kind of massage
she never objected out loud in that
scenario
to him or anybody else correct
she didn't say that she didn't say she
objected is there any evidence
that she yelled out or hollered out help
no there's no evidence
that she ever called the police she
didn't tell me that
let me ask that question again there's
no other ship called the police correct
i'm basing this testimony on what she
told me and she didn't tell me she
called the police so as we sit here in
the universe of evidence that we do have
i'm not asking you to speculate about
what we don't have
i'm just asking what is in front of this
court there's no evidence in front of
the sport
that she ever called the police correct
correct
okay so she got into the shower
of her own free will correct
i'm not sure i'm not sure it was in her
own free will
well it certainly was the suggestion
according to her it was at the
suggestion of someone
but there's no gun held in anybody's
head right prosecutors told the judge
garcia's lawyers were essentially trying
to blame
the victims they don't want to talk
about the facts of this case
they don't want to talk about the
statements from five victims
about how they were raped by mr garcia
they don't want to talk about how miss
oaxaca
and miss uh more relevantly obviously
miss ocampo would bring these girls to
him
they don't want to talk about these
women
these girls who have complained to the
attorney general's office
about being forced to orally copulate mr
garcia
and they don't want to talk about the
statements by the victims your honor
that oral cop was forced on them
they don't want to talk about the videos
with a young boy
and mr garcia
having an orgy the young boy
having sex with a member of his own
family your honor
they don't want to talk about that
because those facts are not good for
them
in the end the judge ordered garcia to
stand trial the apostle is being held
rhonda on a 90 million dollars bail what
do we hear from the church
well brian we invited members of the
church and his defense attorneys to
appear on the program
they did not respond to our requests for
interviews but a spokesperson for the
church put a statement on their facebook
page
not mentioning the videotapes that were
referenced that we just heard about in
court
but saying that these were outlandish
claims outlandish evidence from
anonymous sources
and assuring their followers that the
apostle was an innocent
and honorable man
all right rhonda thank you coming up
we're going to hear from a young woman
who was recruited to be part of that sex
ring at the age of nine
she's now broken with the church and
telling her story
when we return you're watching the law
and crime trial network
continuing our coverage now the
allegations against the so-called
apostle
we're going to hear from a young woman
one of the few who is willing to speak
out
about what she says has happened
he is jesus he's jesus here on earth
he was the purest
most perfect man on earth nathan joaquin
garcia
is called the apostle by the millions of
followers
who he claims belong to his light of the
world church
an evangelical fundamentalist church
active in every state in the united
states
and in dozens of other countries around
the world
so everything that i was taught to do
for him
it wasn't wrong it was
it was a ble it was blessing it was a
blessing
but now sochil martin says she knows
better that what she did for the apostle
was wrong very wrong and now she's
coming forward
in this interview and in a lawsuit set
to be filed soon
claiming the apostle turned her into a
sex slave
and ordered her to help him recruit
young boys and girls
for sex trafficking did you see times
where there were girls under the age of
17 who were involved in a sexual
relationship or having sex
with nason yes
all the time in which he was yes
having sex with them yes essentially
raping them right yes
i i was there
you saw that i saw that often
occasionally
often it was an everyday thing
social martin's account comes as the
church leader is already behind bars in
los angeles
awaiting trial on sex trafficking
charges brought by the california
attorney general
he has pleaded not guilty the type of
crimes that belong
nowhere in our society from human
trafficking
production of child pornography oral
copulation
rape statutory rape
child molestation extortion
conspiracy and more so
chill says she's now cooperating with
the california attorney general
and with the fbi and federal prosecutors
the first
alleged victim of garcia to speak
publicly i was a
member of the church for 30 years of my
life
i was born into the church fourth
generation
my great-grandparents my grandparents
were one of the first members of the los
angeles church
the church is run like a family business
it was founded by garcia's grandfather
in guadalajara mexico he was the first
self-proclaimed apostle
a title he passed on to his son samuel
so chill says it was samuel who first
introduced her
to the dark side of the church i was
nine
9 10 years old when i was
taught and taken to samuel and you're
you're right when you say it's a dark
place just because
even when you're that young you know
something's off
no matter what they tell you but she
says inside the church
the young girls recruited for the
apostle are considered
special encouraged even by their own
mothers to serve him
you think that you're chosen and you're
you're taught that you're
lucky you're lucky to be there and that
you're
the rest of the girls that you're around
wow out of all of these girls in the
church thousands and thousands of
members of the church in this
congregation out of all of them
i i'm chosen when you're taken to
a private room or to one of his private
homes
or his private properties and you're
forced to
take your clothes off for them and touch
them
and seduce them in a way that an older
woman would
your mother was actually encouraging you
to do this
she took me yes she would buy things for
me and she would take me physically and
knowing what was going on yes and she
would speak to him before and after
why would she do that
she thought it was okay she herself
she was young she was she was with him
she was one of his concubines
so i'm guessing that she thought that it
was okay to do it
later as a high school student in los
angeles attending john marshall high
school so chill says
she was then seduced and molested by
nelson garcia
who was married at the time but not yet
crowned the apostle
he would caress my my butt ex
and my waist and the sides of my breasts
so in my head again i still try to
believe that
it wasn't that bad but it's bad
and i guess if you want to call it that
it is
he molested me at age 16.
and i didn't see it that way so schill
says when mason took over running the
church following the death of his father
the relationship grew more extensive and
weirder
including recording scenes of group sex
with so chill and
underage girls naked
during sexual affairs and
you know and he would record with
phones and ipads and tablets and he had
his computer
he would download all of it and he would
he would keep that with him
in fact the california prosecutors have
said in court they have recovered scores
of the apostles
phones and tablets and computers with
sex tapes of
underage children there's devices that
have
content that we've identified as child
pornography does it bother you that
you're in those videos it does just
because
in the moment when you're there you
think it's a blessing
but things came to a head so jill martin
says when she refused to perform a sex
act on a 14 year old boy
in front of the boy's mother and the
apostle
she says the apostle was furious at her
refusal
and gave her a beating after the
situation with him
with the little boy he calls me back and
that's what happened he
he
he leaned me over and he he
struck me until i couldn't feel my right
leg
you tell them to stop
you can't tell him to stop
you can't tell him no you can't tell him
this isn't right you can't tell him it
hurts you can't tell him you can't tell
him that you're
unhappy you can't tell you can't tell
him that you're in pain
you can't tell him that you're confused
you can't say any of that
lawyers for the apostle have already
attacked sochil martin
saying in court papers they have
uncovered new evidence of social
martin's
own criminal conduct saying she groomed
underage girls in an attempt to extort
mr garcia
showing them how to pose sexy and
allegedly telling
others she was in love with mr garcia
and repeatedly described him as her
everything when he asked you to be with
these
young women minor girls
you went along with that
you don't have a choice
you don't have a choice like
everything in my being
my mind my my body everything i was
taught my entire life
was that that was okay it was done to me
it was done to my mom it was done to
all those other girls that i grew up
around and their moms were okay with it
social martin has now left the church
and is in the california witness
relocation program
treated as an outcast by her family with
the church
denouncing her wherever they can i lost
my family
i lost friends i lost my society
i lost my world i fell down i
i was beat up i was kicked i was
emotionally physically mentally
the bravest thing i ever did was get
back up
when i wanted to die and
that's what i feel happened so now that
i'm
up i feel like it's my responsibility
to keep going try all you want but the
truth is there and justice is there
and it's waiting for you
any day now the manhattan district
attorney may get his hands on donald
trump's tax returns
and if he does our next two guests say
mr trump could be
in a world of hurt
we're joined now by john moscow a former
top prosecutor in the manhattan district
attorney's office who made his name
prosecuting
complex and international financial
crimes around the world
and also by david k johnson a former
pulitzer prize
journalist who has written two trump
books the making of donald trump
and it's even worse than you think dave
is now a visiting lecturer
at the syracuse university law school
and david let me start with you this now
appears to be much more than an
investigation
into hush money payments into the two
women who said they had affairs with
donald trump
well that's what all the news reports
are saying but in the very beginning
they said they were looking for records
as far back as 2011 which is way before
this
i've always viewed this as a garden
variety tax fraud case
involving donald trump the trump family
the trump organization
and well there certainly is an element
here that deals with the hush money
payments
uh i think this has always been much
broader than that and i think that's now
eminently clear from what's in the
judicial decision we got from judge
katzman of the second circuit court of
appeals
and john moscow if you were in your own
job prosecuting economic crimes
in the district attorney's office what
kind of a case would you be bringing
well i have no idea what the evidence is
but if the newspaper stories are correct
then there are a host of
offenses involving false business
records
false letters or financial statements to
banks and to insurance companies
possibly false tax returns certainly
michael cohen makes that
pretty clear and if you take all these
relatively low level economic crimes
you can put them into what is called
enterprise corruption
where if you have a business which is in
the business of committing crimes
the it becomes the equivalent of a
25-year felony like bank robbery
and there have been white-collar
criminal enterprises i prosecuted one
with a landlord who was falsifying
documents we prosecuted a large number
of them involving corrupt brokerage
firms
if in fact david is correct
and by the way i love your textbooks
david if
david is correct and if the documents
are false going out to banks
to insurance companies to accounting
firms
then you have a relatively
clear case but then you have to figure
out
who is responsible and what the evidence
is there i simply do not have any idea
at all
so david k johnston in this case we can
see why donald trump's fighting so hard
to keep his tax doctors from being
turned over
well he is but he doesn't have any
ammunition
judge katzman wrote a very nuanced and
substantial 36-page opinion
where he does everything short of
calling the president's lawyers and the
u.s government's lawyers acting on
trump's behalf
out for making frivolous arguments and
you are both lawyers you know that about
the worst thing a judge can ever say to
a litigant is that your argument is
frivolous but again and again
detail by detail judge katzman who's a
legal scholar has published legal
textbooks
walks through why there is simply
no case supporting the president's
claims
and in several places basically accuses
trump's lawyers of
misleading the court which is also a
very serious matter
in front of a judge and john moscow
trump's still fighting to turning over
the tax documents but
once psy vance gets them in the
manhattan district attorney's office
what would you say is the timetable for
further action
there is no one alive who would know
that because
it really depends on what they reveal
who the witnesses are
you can't say if we get this one piece
we're set to go
there's an awful lot of evidence over a
number of years
you have to see which of the people have
been involved in
at least three what they call pattern
acts
because those people are eligible
to be part of the overall indictment
and you know between six months and a
year
would be a reasonable guesstimate but
it's just a guess
you really don't know until
you see what the evidence is and how
much is produced
the accounting firm could simply be
saying we were instructed to file this
and we filed it
or they could be going through far more
complicated conversations in which they
discussed
the propriety of claiming tax deductions
and
the accuracy of business records so
that they've been working on it for a
while
they know what they're looking for but
until they know what they get
no one can really predict how long it
will take
and david johnson let me ask you this as
trump
fights this off what happens if he is
re-elected back in the white house for
four years
can the manhattan district attorney
bring any kind of action against him as
he's in office
well he can't prosecute him he can
indict him
at the state level and trump will
undoubtedly fight that but he will not
be able
to force him to go to trial in fact
judge katzman's decision talks about
that
and if i can just build a little bit off
of what john said
the district attorney in new york
already has trump state tax returns
he has the federal information the irs
has
given to the state what he doesn't have
are the account accounting banking
and presumably some business records
because there's been some cooperation by
the trump organization
and that apparently it slowed or even
stopped so
what they're looking for i think is
proof to tie
together the documents they already have
from the tax returns to whether
those tax returns are false what
business records were falsified
if there are memos ordering people to do
things that are improper
but they already got a lot of the
information and probably feel rather
confident about what they have
and this appears to be in large part a a
document based case right john
in large part but testimony is going to
be very
very important because
not all the documents were signed by the
potential defendants
you need to tie them to the
various falsifications
i you know enterprise corruption is a
very interesting statute
because it also provides for the
forfeiture of the enterprise
that is the criminal enterprise so that
if for example the trump organization
were to be determined
by the grant jury to be a criminal
enterprise
then it would be subject to forfeiture
which is an angle which i don't think
the defendants have necessarily focused
on though i'm sure their lawyers have
so you know yes they they bottom line
very serious case yeah
oh yes no this is as serious as they get
in white-collar crime
david k johnson finally uh what's your
prediction of what happens next
well it's it depends on how quickly the
courts move in terms of the political
ramifications of this
uh the second circuit sent the matter
back
once again to the district court judge
although
based on what has happened there i
expect that this will be disposed of
very quickly
uh trump will take it back again to the
court of appeals uh he'll try to get at
the supreme court which i'd be very
surprised if they hear it
and i wouldn't be shocked if trump then
seeks his remedies in state court
even though he was the one who chose
federal court
as the forum to attack what the
prosecutors are doing
but delay delay delay is the name of the
game for trump
because as john moscow points out quite
rightly under
new york's little rico statute
he's at risk of losing absolutely
everything and going to prison
well the heat is on i want to thank both
of you for joining us
john moscow former prosecutor in the
manhattan district attorney's office
and david k johnson a pulitzer
prize-winning journalist
author of two books on trump and a
visiting lecturer
at the syracuse university school of law
thank you both for being here tonight
thank you thank you take care
and now it's time for this week's
winners and losers in the
media as selected by the editors of
mediaite and we're joined by the
editor-in-chief of mediaite aidan
mclaughlin
and like the long crime network mediaite
is part of the dan abrams
media empire aidan thanks for being here
today
thanks ryan let's start with the first
winner
sandra smith that's right so sandra
smith is a fox news anchor
she hosts the uh 9 a.m to noon
show america's newsroom on fox and she's
quite good at grilling
trump campaign members and trump white
house officials
that's what we got a taste of last week
he said he has heard about the online
conspiracy theorist
his words were he has heard about them
and that they are people that love
our country it was puzzling to many
people
he's talking about his supporters he
believes his supporters are good hard
working people
that love this country he's not in the
business of basket of deplorable
politics
he doesn't talk about it he wants to
think about it
the fbi released a memo last year
warning that q anon's followers could be
possible quote conspiracy
theory driven domestic extremists so
just to reiterate
the president did comment on it um
saying that these are people that love
our country
so she really challenged yeah really
challenged her and
and rightfully so uh the president got
asked about q anon which is this sort of
crazy cult
uh that sort of worship worshiped him uh
at a press briefing
and he said that these are people who
love our country he didn't disavow the
group
uh he didn't say anything critical about
them and he wasn't
referring to his supporters he was
referring to believers in q anon which
uh as you know fox news sort of expertly
did there and it was sort of a move that
they might have picked up from cnn
uh in fact you'd see it more on that
with network than on fox
they put up a fact check uh that listed
out q and on beliefs
as kaylee mcani was saying that the
president has no idea what they are
even though they're well known by the
fbi um so it was well done it was a good
grilling on this
um and kaylee mcinnady didn't really
have an answer
a strong showing by fox news at least on
that morning show
how about to your next loser steve
bannon
the former uh trump advisor white house
official
yeah steve bennett had a pretty bad week
last week uh
he got indicted uh in manhattan for
uh basically uh scamming donors to this
group that he had founded
called we build the wall it was a
gofundme that he started
with a few business partners partners
last year and the idea was that they
would raise
money privately to build president
donald trump's border wall which he
promised in 2016 in the 2016 campaign
um you know steve bannon if you'll
recall uh was his campaign manager back
then
so they raised 25 million dollars and in
the indictment of steve bannon
uh it's alleged that uh nearly a million
of those dollars he used for personal
expenses
um so it's a little bit of a bad look
for someone who sold themselves as sort
of like a populist
leader um and he you know he was
arrested by police
on uh the yacht of a chinese billionaire
and he was released on a 5 million bond
so
not a great look for steve bannon um and
he's now faces charges
um that he's sort of built donald trump
supporters uh he says it's all part of a
grand conspiracy theory
and that these are just you know
manhattan deep state trying to stop the
wall being built
i think that probably strange credulity
yet another trump adviser facing
criminal charges
and by the trump justice department your
next winner john
berman at cnn let's take a look at what
he said
you do lead the coronavirus task force
as of this morning 174
000 americans have lost their lives to
this pandemic
as we sit here this morning what is the
projection you're looking at
for the number of americans who will
lose their lives by the end of the year
a good tough question why is he a media
winner this week aidan
so mike pence appeared on a series of tv
shows the morning after
the last night of the dnc basically to
give the administration's response to
democrats
john berman had by far the best
interview with mike pence it went on for
more than 15 minutes uh he questioned
pence on the coronavirus pandemic
and when the vice president said that uh
you know the administration's response
to it was
excellent uh as he frequently does john
berman pointed out the death toll which
is exceedingly high
um higher than even initial projections
uh predicted
um and he really pressed the vice
president on that he also questioned the
vice president about q anon
um like uh fox did kaylee mcenany uh and
the vice president had a similar
response which was that the president
has never heard of this
um and that it's not a you know it's not
a problem that they're looking at
um i can i just give you my hot take on
q anon since we're back on that
subject you bet yes so i actually think
it's
it's a mistake for reporters to ask the
president about q anon
um it's a sort of crazy cult um that
believes that he's fighting against
you know satan worshipers and pedophiles
in the government
um but you know q anon is not something
that the president has really ever heard
of the president we also know has an
inability to criticize
anyone who praises him so a reporter
going into a press conference knows that
the president's not going to disavow
this murderous call he's not going to
say anything insightful about it because
he doesn't really know what it is
and all you're doing is giving air to it
and allowing the believers to think that
they're backed by the president of the
united states
everyone loses i don't think it's a good
idea to ask him about q and on
i think you're right about that you're
going to get an expected answer
it may make for a good headline or a
good clip but doesn't really advance the
country's knowledge about what's going
on that's the thing yep
exactly yeah all right next to your next
a loser
robert o'neal yeah so
robert o'neil is a former navy seal you
probably know him as a member of steel
team six who is credited with killing
osama bin laden
uh he has since become uh a pundit a
conservative pundit he does speaking
tours
uh he appears on fox news quite a bit uh
and
uh and recently he posted a photo of
himself
on a delta flight uh without wearing a
mask a face mask
you'll see there there's a man behind
him with a marine cat who is wearing a
face mask
now the caption that accompanied this
photo uh was robert o'neill saying i'm
not a and i'm not going to say the word
because i'm not sure if i'm allowed to
um but it's another word for a cat and
that was obviously met with
you know some outrage on social media
because he's defiantly violating you
know mask rules
it also got the attention of delta the
new york post reached out to
the airline and asked them if they had
seen this photo of him violating their
mask rule
uh delta subsequently banned robert
o'neill from ever flying on the airline
again
uh this is an incredibly stupid thing to
do
not only because delta has quite clear
mask policies as does every airline
um proudly flaunting it getting banned
from an airline and then complaining
about why you were banned for flaunting
uh for defying their quite obvious um
you know airline policy for wearing
masks on on delta flights
uh is an easily a lose of the loss of
the day and i'm not sure why he did it
complete loser and finally your winner
brian stelter of cnn
somewhat of a competitor of yours
somewhat of a competitor of ours and
yeah and
you know reading this book his new book
is called hoax um
it's about sort of the relationship
between trump and fox news uh
it reads like sort of you know a
collection of mediaite's coverage of the
network and of the white house
but with a lot of really interesting
insights and additional reporting
um that gives us a really good look at
that relationship
uh the book itself has been wildly
successful
uh it's number one on amazon right now
and actually simon
schuster his publisher brian selter just
announced this morning that they had to
do an additional
order of hardcovers for the book uh
totaling it 150
000 which is a lot i'd say for a book
that sort of focuses on the niche of
cable news and the white house
um but it's been such a defining story
these past couple years
um that incestuous relationship and sort
of symbiotic relationship between
the top stars at fox news be it sean
hannity tucker carlson
and the white house um it's very often a
network that drives policy
uh for trump and it also drives sort of
the news cycle forward because trump
will watch the network
see something that he likes on it start
tweeting about it and suddenly that's
what everyone's covering for the rest of
the day
um and brian filter does a really good
job in the book of breaking down
uh how that process happens and also how
it's sort of a pretty unprecedented
relationship between a white house and a
cable news network
an important book aid mclaughlin thank
you so much for joining us today
thanks brian
and thanks for our team at law and crime
for getting us on the air and off here
[Music]
you